PAUL IRISH: Hi.
So we're back here at GDL
Presents, where we interview
unique and talented developers
who are developing really
compelling stuff.
Today we have with us Mark
Danks, who you might be
familiar with his work
at "My Robot Nation."
How's it going, Mark?
MARK DANKS: It's going well.
Good to see you.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
Great.
So you led development of "My
Robot Nation," which has this
builder, which is this
incredible app that uses WebGL
to kind of create a
rich experience.
Do you want to talk a little
bit about, kind of from a
consumer perspective, how
this whole thing works?
MARK DANKS: Sure.
So what we were looking to do
was really make it easy and
accessible for people to get
access to 3D printing.
And we sort of were scratching
our heads at what would be
this awesome thing, and really
realized that little
customizable robot
sort of figurines
would be pretty cool.
Because each one would
be totally unique.
And so we thought about writing
an app, or a desktop
app, or something, and realized
that we could do it
all in a browser.
And it just seems to make the
most sense to do that.
So basically, you go
to the browser.
It runs full WebGL,
so it's all in 3D.
But my background's all
in video games.
And so I sort of approached it
of, how do you make these
complicated things really easy
to understand, where it's sort
of just drag and drop?
You don't have to know anything
about 3D graphics.
You don't have to know
how to model.
But literally, it's
an infinite--
billions and billions of
combinations of these
different robot shapes
that you can get.
And they're all in full color.
So you can put a hat
on your robot.
You can pick different
body parts.
And once you like it, and got it
all posed, and ready to go,
you can go ahead and we'll 3D
print it, and send it to you
in the mail.
PAUL IRISH: Great.
Yeah.
It's really powerful.
And it's pretty rad to create
your own robot and then get an
actual physical version
in a few weeks.
So why don't you talk a little
bit about how this was
constructed?
Because it's really fantastic.
So one of the things that has
always been really interesting
to me is seeing someone from the
video game industry, and
bringing them into the web, and
kind of seeing what their
development experience
is like there.
How did you kind of approach
just getting into it, of kind
of ascertaining what your
development stack was going to
be like, and how you were
actually going to construct
with the new primitives
available on the web platform?
MARK DANKS: Yeah.
So the way I approached it
first was really thinking
about, you know--
there are two main aspects to
the engine itself and sort of
the interface.
One of it is the
3D side of it.
And so that's some really heavy
JavaScript sitting in
the background.
And that's basically--
it's a full-on game engine.
We do collision detection,
all kinds of stuff.
And that, luckily, I sort of--
I have some experience on how
to handle that, how to write
all the shaders and that
kind of thing.
So I was able to basically
translate what, for me, used
to be hardcore C++ code
into JavaScript.
And was really--
at the time, honestly, I was
kind of skeptical if this
could work.
You know, how do you
[? do array ?] test against
10,000 triangles
kind of stuff.
And it just does.
It works, totally interactive,
60 frames a second, no
problems at all.
So that was pretty awesome for
just getting the graphic side
of it, the WebGL side.
And then one thing that we did
differently, I think, is
really going, we're
on the web.
The web is all about
interfaces.
So rather than try to create
the interface that you
interact with where you pick
your attachments, and your
stamps, and your
robot pieces--
rather than making that more 3D,
which is really a pain in
the neck to develop for,
we actually do all
that in normal HTML.
Now again, we're using things
like jQuery and some pretty
complex CSS, but the idea was
we could bring the two
together in a way that
you really can't
do on a lot of platforms.
So that was a really
nice thing.
So I could spend all my
3D efforts and all my
visualization in JavaScript and
kind of treating it like a
game engine.
But then when we wanted to
deal with how people were
going to actually interact with
it and select all their
stuff, we could just treat it
as a normal page, and just
have the two parts talk
to each other.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
And so a challenge for a lot of
people with WebGL is that
dealing with the actual GL
primitives is pretty foreign.
And so a lot of people just
hop into using a library.
Now you luckily have a lot of
experience, which makes
working inside the OpenGL ES 2
kind of environment a bit more
comfortable.
Was there any third-party code
that you kind of used in the
construction of the application
to kind of assist,
in probably not that,
but other parts?
MARK DANKS: Yeah.
For the actual 3D WebGL stuff,
we wrote it all.
And again, from my background,
I'm a video game
developer in the past.
So I'm used to writing on
PlayStation 2 and 3, for Xbox,
things like that.
So it's pretty much OpenGL,
DirectX, all no problems.
So for me, that was no problem
dealing with shaders and how
you handle all the
actual low-level
vertex buffers and that.
It was pretty easy.
So for that, that's all
completely ours.
On the interface side, I mean,
the one thing we are using is
jQuery, very heavily.
So sort of all of the state
transformations, and
animations, and movement
you see on that UI are
all done that way.
And so that was a pretty
powerful thing, so we didn't
have to reinvent all
those wheels.
And again, that's
kind of what--
when we were looking at it--
we're looking at how the slice
it of the web side versus the
3D side, and really bringing
the two together.
So the main one was probably
the jQuery
library that we used.
PAUL IRISH: So inside the
application, I get to kind of
choose the head, and
the torso, and
the legs of my robot.
There's a bunch of
different models.
I can choose specific ones.
I can randomize.
I can then color them all.
For these actual components--
so these are all 3D models.
How did you basically take that
from a 3D model that was
designed in a modeling
application, and bring it out
into something that you
can now see in Web GL?
Kind of, what's the process
for taking that there?
MARK DANKS: Yeah.
So we had a bunch of modelers
who worked with us.
And they're standard
game modelers or
worked in special effects.
So they're used to using
programs like Maya and Max.
They're the high-end
modeling packages.
And in that case, we just
exported to sort of a generic
format called OBJ.
It's kind of a lingua franca
for the industry.
And then I just wrote a
converter that basically spit
out all the stuff, WebGL
ready to go.
So I could just load it directly
in the vertex buffers
and things like that.
So for me, it's a fairly
straightforward pipeline.
The kind of interesting thing
about how we have to do, is
since we have the additional
wrinkle of 3D printing, what
we 3D print and what you
interact with on the screen
are actually different
geometries.
So on the screen, your robot's
about 10,000 polygons.
We print the robot at about
half a million.
So we actually go through a
pretty big translation step on
the back end, where we literally
recreate everything
you've done on the screen,
and convert it to
a print-ready model.
So that was actually one of the
bigger challenges, of sort
of how do you-- what you'd see
on the screen, if you print
it, like nothing
would be round.
Everything would be faceted
and angular.
You can't pull tricks with
normals and shading in the
real world type stuff.
So yeah, so we actually have
this entire translation
process that occurs.
It's kind of an interesting
thing that, when it's running
actually in the browser, every
frame, basically, I destroy
the robot and re-create
it from scratch.
So every single texture, every
single model, every single
component--
I rebuild from these
instructions.
So every frame is [INAUDIBLE]
redoing all of that.
And then we spit out that same
sort of instruction set.
And that's the part then, that
we take these high-resolution
3D models, run it through
another tool that reconstructs
that, and makes a
printable model.
PAUL IRISH: Wow.
Oh, that's fantastic.
So one question I just had, the
[? OBJ ?] format that you
export the models as--
is that sent down in a
serialized format to the
browser, which then interprets
it, and brings it up?
MARK DANKS: Yeah.
No, we convert it to
a JSON format.
So that basically with that,
I use this for two reasons.
One is that we need to just
load it directly into the
WebGL vertex buffers and
texture coordinates and
normals and all that
kind of stuff.
So that's just a straight--
load in the buffer,
we're done.
The other thing that is--
since we do accurate collision
tests against the models--
I actually use that
exact same data.
It's basically massaged in a way
that the WebGL can handle
it, but then my collision code
can handle it as well.
So we can then go off and
do all the collision on
the exact same data.
And there, I have to
get the normals.
I have to get the
UV coordinates.
So I need all the
data anyways.
So rather than try to split it
apart, send double the data
down, I sort of have a little
custom format that we made
that just encapsulates
it all in one type.
PAUL IRISH: That's fantastic.
So I'm curious--
a lot--
typically with applications like
this, what people might
run into is that the amount of
data, like the models that
they're sending down or
everything else--
it gets quite big.
So on the web, you have the
challenge of, you're sending
out all the bytes to the user
that they're going to see.
And they can be sizable.
So kind of like, what are
the challenges that
you ran into there?
And how did you solve
performance, load
time, things like that?
MARK DANKS: Yeah.
So we started doing
it in two ways--
well three, maybe.
The honest truth is, we just
went, we hope people have a
fast net connection.
And just all of the data
down the pipeline.
But that being said, then what
we did is we did a lot of
optimization.
So we do everything from welding
our vertices, removing
dead things.
My JSON format is fairly
compressed.
So like, if I'm sending a float
down, I'll look at how
many digits am I actually
sending, and I'll strip it
back, and things like that.
So we were able to get it from
sort of a brain dead, F print
float type mindset.
We usually able to reduce
it down about a
third from that size.
So that was good.
The other thing is we're
not doing any
tricks with the textures.
They're just straight up
PNGs we send through.
But they are compressed.
The other thing though, that we
do do there, is when you're
interacting in the browser,
the textures, the PNG ,
stamps, are just 128 by 128.
PAUL IRISH: Uh.
MALE SPEAKER: We can
edit this in post.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What happened?
Did we lose him?
PAUL IRISH: Mark's back.
MARK DANKS: Oh--
how much of that was lost?
MALE SPEAKER: Still there?
MARK DANKS: Yeah, we're
still here.
PAUL IRISH: We lost the
last third of it.
MARK DANKS: OK.
I'll say it again.
PAUL IRISH: OK.
MARK DANKS: OK, so--
PAUL IRISH: Here, let me--
I'll prompt you--
MARK DANKS: You'll
ask the question?
PAUL IRISH: Yep.
So Mark, typically you run
into a problem with
applications like this, that
you're sending down this model
data, you're sending out
a lot of other things.
And you have to deal with the
fact that it adds up to quite
a few bytes.
Now what kind of challenges did
you run into in regard to
like performance and
load time, and how
did you solve them?
MARK DANKS: Yeah.
So there are sort of two main
places where we're sending
lots of data.
One is the geometry itself.
And in that one, since the
sort of internal data for
collision and all that is the
exact same as the rendering,
we don't have to
double that up.
So that was one nice thing.
Then I did a lot of
optimizations on-- the data we
send through is in JSON format,
and I actually really
massage it, so the floating
point numbers, we use as
smallest numbers as possible.
And I was able to get down from
sort of a naive export
out of my tool, down about a
third of the size, really
looking at how much resolution
in the UV coordinates do I
actually need?
OK, I don't need out to the
millions place, only send two
digits kind of thing.
Then the other thing is on the
textures, those are actually
128 by 128 inside the engine.
So they're pretty small
thumbnails, basically.
But then when we generate the
print model on the back end,
we actually use 1024 by 1024.
So again, we're able to sort
of trick it, and only send
through the data we need.
So you can see what it will look
like, but then when we go
to the print model, we can use
these really high-resolution
textures that are just
awesome-looking.
The other thing that we do
heavily, heavily, heavily, is
the entire engine is
asynchronous loading.
So we don't load anything
until it's needed.
And in fact, if you select a
part, we don't even load it
until it would appear
on the robot.
So for instance, if you select
the top hat, you can
immediately select it.
We don't do any loading.
We just wait.
And then you actually move over
the model and now, OK, we
have to see the top hat--
that's when we
finally load it through.
PAUL IRISH: I see.
That's really smart.
So yeah, this is really
powerful.
I'm wondering, when you were
building it, was there any
issues where you kind of wished
that you had some extra
feature that was just not
available in the browsers you
were targeting, or any
challenges like that?
MARK DANKS: Well, yeah.
I mean, I wish WebGL was a
little more ubiquitous.
But that was something that we
decided early on that we
needed to go for the best
experience, and we
just go with it.
Interestingly enough, I've
actually made change that's on
some of our other apps now,
where if you don't have WebGL,
we actually render
and canvas 2D.
And it turned out to
be really easy.
I kind of wrote it
in a weekend.
And the reason was because I
had all the collision data,
which was the triangles, and so
all I do is I just project
it into canvas as tri's.
I do a depth sort on all the
triangles, and you're set.
So we actually have
a fallback now.
And so I can actually run-- not
"My Robot Nation"-- but
some of our other apps, I can
run on my iPhone and my iPad
without a problem.
PAUL IRISH: Oh, that's
really cool.
MARK DANKS: So that was
kind of cool to see.
I think the general thing that
we were seeing with it is just
that we're so JavaScript
heavy.
And so it was--
over the development--
it was in development for six or
nine months kind of thing.
It was really cool to see the
browsers getting better and
better on the JavaScript side.
And literally, we started
telling-- by the end, we could
tell the modelers "add more
polygons." You can do it now.
Whereas in the beginning, we
were really restricted on what
was possible there.
A lot of the stuff that--
I was doing some pretty weird
optimizations on my math
libraries, just trying
to trick the
browser into going fast--
and by the end, it was sort of,
good, I don't have to do
that anymore.
And so that was really
a nice thing that--
if you're doing a little
one-off, give, show, hide kind
of thing, you don't
really care.
But when you're doing something
like this, that's
trying to run at 60 frames,
suddenly, your performance
matters a lot.
PAUL IRISH: Yep.
Absolutely.
MARK DANKS: Yeah.
I think other things that I look
at and look forward to
are a lot more binary support
for data coming to the system.
So that's the kind of thing
where, if I had
an easy way to encode--
basically my JSON
file is binary--
that would be pretty cool.
A lot of the stuff-- that
there's a lot of people doing
work, I know, on texture
compression, and like
decompressing it in a shader.
So stuff like that is--
I've been watching pretty
closely and kind of waiting
for it to become a little
more mainstream
before putting it in.
But the new projects we're
looking at are even bigger
than this one.
So we're trying to find ways
that we can keep on pushing
the content down.
I think definitely our next big
effort is really on, how
do we get the bandwidth
requirements down?
Because once it's on the
client, it seems
to run pretty well.
But getting there
is the problem.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
I'm curious about kind of--
staying in tune with some of
these conversations and the
features that are being
standardized and being imposed,
it's a little tricky
sometimes to kind of
monitor where these
conversations are happening.
How are you tracking, for
instance, texture compression,
or things like that?
MARK DANKS: Yeah.
So thankfully, it's
really awesome.
We got hooked in with the WebGL
community pretty early.
And we actually presented
it to [? SIGGRAPH ?]
Birds of a Feather a
couple years ago.
And that's sort of where we sort
of burst on the scene and
got introduced to everyone.
So now we do it-- it's
everything from the mailing
list-- which is really helpful
and really, really good.
A lot of stuff happens there.
Most of the people know I kind
of lurk, but I read every
single thing that
goes through.
And then--
I'm based in San Francisco--
and so we have WebGL meet-ups
once a month.
So those are pretty good, where
lots of presentations
are given and talking about
what's going on.
I presented there.
Actually, my company's hosting
the next one on October 25th.
So that kind of thing is a good
place to meet people who
are doing this, and sort of
find out what's going on.
And also it's really--
all the people who are helping
make WebGL real are really
open, and accessible, and really
easy to talk with.
So that's been a really
nice thing as well.
PAUL IRISH: Awesome.
Well I encourage everyone to go
check out "My Robot Nation"
and dig under the covers
a little bit.
It's a really well-developed
app, and creates a great
experience--
one of the first great, solid
WebGL apps that's definitely
not a demo.
And it's real, creates a real
thing that you can hold, even.
So I encourage everyone to
go check it out, see
what's going on.
And Mark, thank you very
much for joining us and
telling us about it.
MARK DANKS: So one other
thing, if I can
make a plug, here--
we're going to actually
expand it a bit.
And I'm actually in charge
of a another group called
cubify.com.
And one of the things we're
going to be releasing here in
the next couple months
is actually an SDK.
So people can use this
engine to make their
own 3D printed models.
So that's something which--
keep an eye open for it--
probably end of October,
November time-frame, this code's
going to be out and
sort of fully supported.
PAUL IRISH: Great.
And say the name of it again?
MARK DANKS: It's cubify.com.
And if you go there, you'll
see a bunch of other apps.
In fact, just last week,
we released an Android
customization app.
So you can make your own
Android with the same
techniques.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
That's rad.
All right.
Nice.
Well, thanks again, Mark.
This has been great.
MARK DANKS: Thank you so much.
PAUL IRISH: All right, cheers.